hey everybody is Charlie welcome to
Fight Night Superman vs destro this is
going to be a breakdown of their epic
battles in the video games in the comics
and on arrow I know we'd like to see
Deathstroke versus Supergirl and I think
it goes similar way as it went in the
comics so here we go there is a new
round of the flash ring giveaway going
on now all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
while everything's on break so there are
a couple different versions of this
fight that you might have seen whether
you've read the comics or you played the
Grand Theft Auto mod there's like a
Grand Theft Auto hack-and-slash mod so
I'll play like a little clip from that
real quick you can see what it looks
like
[Music]
it's an open world mod it's not like the
injustice fight where it's like
predetermined that's actually built into
the game that way
[Music]
with Superman's regime toppled new
governments formed to take its place new
government's meant new customers for
Deathstroke and business was booming
soon there were more assassinations to
carry out revolutions to aid and unrest
to create than he could manage on his
own the one earth regimes elite troopers
having committed atrocities and
Superman's name had gone into hiding
from a populist bent on revenge
impossible for most to find but not for
Deathstroke recruiting these renegades
he formed the new Titans the world's
premier political assassins if you don't
know about injustice maybe you play the
game but the basic story is as you know
what would happen in the darkest
timeline if Superman went against the
world something happened like Lois Lane
was killed it drove him mad and he
became a god on earth acting like a very
angry god on earth the comic book
version of the fight that just went down
in Deathstroke rebirth number 8 is
basically Superman going to stop
Deathstroke from killing a bunch of
people so Deathstroke has been hired to
kill this person or at least he tells
Superman that he's going after this
warlord who's responsible for killing a
bunch of people Superman doesn't believe
in murdering anyone no matter how bad
they are so they go at it because
Deathstroke wants to get his mark but
that's his big thing completing
contracts that he's been hired on so the
whole twist here is predicated on
Deathstroke taking advantage of
Superman's weaknesses which are
kryptonite obviously but also the idea
that he is a fundamentally good person
and will pull his punches so Deathstroke
uses that to his advantage to try and
misdirect Superman he has a special icon
shield which is like a brand new thing
that his other son Jericho has that I'll
explain in a second but it's basically a
gravity sheath that reflex kinetic force
so the harder Superman punches in
Deathstroke definitely tries to get him
to punch up harder and harder
just taunting him oh come on Batgirl can
hit harder than that so Superman just
keeps going harder and harder testing
the limits of what the shield is capable
of and it reflects so much force that it
bursts Superman's capillaries and he
starts bleeding so Deathstroke's just
standing there like a boss while the
shield is doing all the work allowing
Superman to beat the [ __ ] out of himself
so eventually he gets away he still
needs to get his mark is going to have
to sink the entire ship but gets
Superman with what he thinks are
kryptonite bullets as he's going to kill
his mark while the ship is going down
Superman's trying to rescue everyone
destroy all these missiles that he's set
off the twist is that he realizes that
this Slade was just trying to misdirect
him while he went to get his mark so he
completes the contract kills the dude
but as it finally looks like Superman
has Deathstroke on the rocks he pulls
his Promethean blade starts absorbing
his heat vision so that the blade itself
can absorb all that energy and then
pierces Superman's skin with it so the
blade itself is just as powerful as
Wonder Woman's ares blade the god killer
sword so it doesn't seem like Superman's
gonna be able to beat him but then big
twist we find out is this Superman has
called in Jericho Slade's son who has a
prototype version of the shield that
Slade's using and is able to disable it
enabling Superman to bring him in so the
whole thing here is as the Deathstroke
will always be able to get the upper
hand on a hero no matter how powerful
they are there's always some weakness to
exploit especially when you're a big boy
scout like Superman part of the fun of
these stories too is in seeing how they
resolve them without making the other
hero look like an idiot because Superman
was playing Deathstroke the whole time
Deathstroke was playing Superman the
whole time so it's a twist with in a
twist within a twist and that's what
Deathstroke stories are all about like
you might think that Deathstroke is
after something trying to kill someone
but there's always some secret motive
behind a secret motive so we find out
that there was a bunch of sensitive
information that was on this ship that
could have caused this huge
international incident and that was part
of the reason why Slade was sent in so
they kind of make it sound like
Deathstroke was hired by the US
government
so that's one of the reasons why I love
the destro character I mean he's a
badass but he exists in this morally
gray area where the people is trying to
kill are arguably worse people like he
tries to justify it to Superman
this person has committed numerous
atrocities they deserve to die
I've been hired to kill them why would
you want to stop that and if you know
anything about Superman of course you
know that he's gonna say no I'm not
gonna allow you to kill this person but
the moral of the story is is that as
long as Deathstroke has his technology
and his toys he will be able to go
toe-to-toe with Superman indefinitely so
let me know in the comments what your
favorite Deathstroke versus Superman
moment from the comics it could be from
any comic they haven't really fought
each other that much usually Deathstroke
fights Batman and he's gonna be in the
Justice League movie that's probably
who's gonna be going after the rumor
right now is that he's gonna be hired by
Lex Luthor to kill Batman
so obviously Ben Affleck isn't going
anywhere so some sort of stalemate is in
the cards hopefully they'll have a
rematch during the Batman movie but I'm
just so excited about Deathstroke in the
movie universe Joe Manganiello is going
to be super badass
remember that teaser that Ben Affleck
dropped earlier in the year of
Deathstroke in his armor so here I'll
play that here again
you
what that is is it's basically like a
mocap setup of what Deathstroke is gonna
look like so they did the same thing
with spider-man homecoming where they
posted a behind-the-scenes of Tom
Holland just dancing around on stage and
they had him in the computer as well it
was like a green screen stage so you can
actually shoot an actor doing a bunch of
action scenes while the computer in real
time puts like a really hardcore looking
suit on top of them so they might tweak
it a little bit but this is a low-res
version of what Deathstroke's armor is
gonna look like in the Justice League
movie and you guys can let me know how
do you want them to incorporate
something more mystical like the idea of
the Promethean blade now we have Wonder
Woman's god-killer sword we know that's
going to be in the movie so there are a
lot of mystical things in the DC
Universe so it would totally fit with
the tone of that but it just depends on
what they want the destro character to
be the arrow version of Deathstroke was
close but they didn't get too deep on
the mythology I think it was all daily
he sacrificed himself for our cause a
good start but the magnitude of your
negligence requires a greater sacrifice
your incompetence has now cost four
lives aldermen fail me again and yours
will be the fifth
[Music]
so if you guys want to recommend another
comic book epic battles video between
two characters just write it below in
the comments I'll say congratulations to
the new flash ring giveaway winner
Michael Ramirez please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details there is a
new round that starts in this video I'll
just announce the winner the next time I
post a DC video I got some more Rick and
Morty that I'll be posting next while
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my flash vs. iris West
video and you can click here to learn
all about Gorilla Grodd thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight